konzentriert und vorausschauend sich
schritt für schritt nach oben arbeiten
das ist es was per zettel am klettern
fasziniert und genau so wünscht er sich
eigentlich die deutsche politik deshalb
ist wählen gehen für den 22-jährigen ein
muss jede junge stimme ist wichtig
findet er die jungen seien ohnehin zu
wenig vertreten
unsere generation hat keine lobby das
ist denke ich das problem also natürlich
hat jetzt auch nicht die ältere
generation irgendwie eine lobby aber
letztendlich sind aber doch die
interessen vieler älterer menschen in
deutschland institutionell besser
repräsentiert als die interessen junger
menschen
tatsächlich sind im deutschen bundestag
nicht mal ein prozent der abgeordneten
unter 30 auch die wähler sind meist
älter und stimmen öfter für konservative
parteien in erfurt wo er wohnt ist jeder
fünfte bewohner über 65 tendenz steigend
er hat oft das gefühl dass es in der
politik zu wenig darum geht was junge
leute brauchen gemerkt hat der student
das etwa in der pandemie als viele
seiner kommilitonen plötzlich
existenzängste hatten
auch ich habe meinen nebenjob verloren
zb eine gastronomie da kenne ich auch
einige filme menschen viele menschen die
dadurch dass sie den nebenjob verloren
haben dann auch im bildungsweg dann
erheblichen einzig bekommen haben viele
haben sogar studium unterbrochen oder
gar abgebrochen
und da wird eben sehr wenig darüber
gesprochen in den vergangenen 18 monaten
war viel zu hause das studium fand meist
nur übers internet statt seine band
tritt nicht mehr auf stattdessen
gitarren übungen im wg zimmer
er sagt viele seiner freunde seien jetzt
vor der bundestagswahl enttäuscht von
der politik und den parteien
[Musik]
das nämlich zumindest in meiner
generation sehr viel war das sehr viel
politikverdrossenheit stattfindet da
sehe ich die rolle meiner generation
gerade auch so ein bisschen das wir von
außen druck ausüben wenn die parteien
sind innerhalb
sehr statisch also man muss einen sehr
langen weg gehen von ortsverein über
plakate kleben bis nun wirklich auch
selbst merkt dass man entscheidungen mit
beeinflussen kann und das frustriert
viele junge menschen
seinen platz sieht er deshalb außerhalb
der parteien
seit zwei jahren engagiert er sich bei
friedrichs for future jede woche treffen
sich die klimaaktivisten trage bereiten
sie eine demonstration vor die kurz vor
der wahl stattfinden soll die
bundestagswahl 2021 wird auf jeden fall
eine richtungsweisende wahr sein dass es
ganz klar die nächste legislatur wird
ohne zweifel darüber entscheiden ob
deutschland die selbst gesetzten
klimaziele aus dem pariser klima
abkommen einhalten kann sprich ob wir
unseren teil dazu beitragen können dass
das 15 grad ziel eingehalten wird die
zeit dränge die politik habe noch immer
nicht verstanden was junge klimaschützer
wie ihn umtreibt ich würde fast sagen
ein stückweit panik denn wir haben wir
sehen auf der ganzen welt überflutungs
katastrophen nicht erst seit diesem jahr
wir sehen hitzewellen dürreperioden
waldbrände auch nicht erst seit diesem
jahr wir sehen unzählige tierarten die
nacheinander aussterben und irgendwie
wirkt es dann doch kein und wir rasen
gerade wirklich mit einem lachenden
gesicht in abgrund zu dass die nächste
regierung das ruder noch herumreißen
glaubt ihr nicht er rechnet damit auch
nach der wahl fürs klima auf die straße
gehen zu müssen